hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well so
aristotle begins the nick of mccain
ethics with this really famous passage
gets translated in all sorts of ways in
part because the greek words that he's
using are kind of ambiguous
but at least it's categorical in saying
every
so every art or skill greek word for
that is tech name
the word we get technology from many of
you are studying techniques
here at mayor's college if you're
studying you're studying some sort of
discipline that will give you some
ability to do things when you're done
right
what else investigations or disciplines
inquiries these sorts of things the word
that he actually uses there's methodos
which we get
method from so think about any sort of
methodological
study of something if you're not
studying a techne
here at marist college you're probably
studying methodos
so any one of your majors and
the the skill or the the discipline
or the job that your major is preparing
you for
he's talking about here what else does
he say in this every list
every action or course of action
praxis is the term there
every thing that we we do this is human
action distinctively human things
and then every choice or commitment
pro-irasis is the word there
which literally means something like
preferring one thing over another
think about it when you make a choice
we've talked about this before what do
you do
you take one alternative and you and you
say well i'd like that other alternative
but not going to happen
when you're ordering goods in relation
to each other and having to sacrifice
one good to another
you're making a choice right so he says
every single one of these
has some sort of end or goal or purpose
that it aims at that's the good
for that thing let's think about some
examples
take some of your majors you know we've
talked about this before
now remind me a little bit we've got
business we've got a lot of calm
people we've got some education majors
what else do we have what are the majors
science natural science
okay oh environmental yeah what else do
we have
fashion fashion okay merchandising or
design okay merchandising
okay so let's let's take each one of
these and think
really you know briefly what is the
point of doing that thing
so let's take fashion merchandise what
is the good
that it attains is it just like making
glossy photos of things and
getting them into a magazine i mean
that's that's an achievement right
that's a measure for a certain kind of
success but is that the the distinctive
good that comes out of it
is that why you're in it because you
really like glossy stuff
no i mean like clothing makes people
happy
okay that's yeah that's very good um
why do people pay more besides you know
labels and things like that
why do people pay more for good clothing
you know good in a lot of different ways
than for
you know the cheap stuff because the
cheap stuff doesn't wear as well
you know you get a good suit
that can last you an awful long time you
get a cheap suit and it doesn't wear
very well
same thing for ties i don't know about
women's stuff because i
don't wear it but presumably it's the
same same sort of deal right
what about the feel when you buy
the more expensive things again putting
aside the prestige factor
does it feel better yeah
it seems kind of silly and trivial but
this is actually quite important stuff
you're you're you know if you're doing
your job well
you're making people's lives better
there's a distinctive good at which you
aim
um what about environment is it you're
doing environmental science
yeah and uh okay but were you a policy
person or um environmental issues policy
concentration okay with a size
minor bio okay
so let's think about the policy because
that goes right to what aristotle is
talking about
what's what's the distinctive good
that's going to come out of that
better health for humans in there yeah
and maybe avoiding killing a bunch of
species that we might actually want to
look at or need
to destroying the landscape
those are pretty good goods those are
important things
what about business what is the is the
distinctive good of business just making
a ton of money
yep really i don't know if you talk with
a lot of business professors
i mean think about every business
professor that you got
if they have any skills
they could be making more money out
there in the workplace than they are
teaching you how to do business
there must be something that attracts
them to that something intrinsic to the
discipline
that maybe not every practitioner
realizes
but it's there why do people
get into business some people do just to
make a lot of money but are there other
reasons why people get into business
i mean who's going to buy your products
you've got to be giving them some sort
of good don't you
or else people don't hand the money over
so if you're
making harps your harps have to look
nice and sound pretty
and people have to like this hour else
they're not going to pay you
if you're selling people coffee
you have to actually you know provide a
probably reliability is a big issue
there too
the coffee should taste the same or less
each time
but you're also providing an experience
too there are distinctive goods with
with each one of these things and the
good is
you know what that activity or that
discipline
aims at now
aristotle makes another distinction here
he says some activities um
they have some sort of good outside of
themselves that they aim so
if you're a barista right
what is the good that you're producing
for people and experience
well the yeah that's part of it with the
experience of what what's what's the
central thing
there it may not be coffee because we
sell tea
at you know starbucks too it's going to
be some sort of
drink right um i guess
that'd be the difference between a
barista the bartender bartender's
selling
alcoholic drinks and you know at least
with
in the old days with starbucks before
they had pre-measured everything
you had to actually know a little bit
about what you were doing they would
train you
and you know you had to like you know
take the coffee and
measure it out and tamp it down and you
know to steam the milk the right way and
all that now it's you know mostly
mechanic mechanicized but um
you were producing something for for the
clients
right that was a good outside of the
activity itself
are there some activities that we engage
in where the good
is that very activity itself
i'll bet you guys engage in some
do any of you who are not athletes play
any sports
you know why do you do it go on yeah
okay so there's an
example of something where you know
you're not doing it for something
outside of the activity itself
you're doing it for that activity um
any musicians in here i think i ask
masterbots
yeah why do you play just just to make
people happy it's fun yeah
the scales are we talked about that
before but
there are there are certain activities
where we do the activity because we want
what's in that activity
you could you could say that about make
sure i've got this turned off
you could say that about certain
commitments that we make too
think about a friendship and we're going
to talk more about this later in the
semester
do you always try to get something out
of your friendships
i mean if you do you may have a kind of
distorted view on relationships if every
single
friendship that you're involved in if
you're in it because you want some
external good that's going to come to
you not the friendship
itself then that's kind of like turning
the cart
you know before the horse
you're making the good that you want
drive the friendship and the friendship
it can be a greater good
than you know connections or getting
invited to parties or
you know a ride somewhere things like
that
so each of these activities each of
these choices all these things that
we're involved with they all have some
sort of purpose
can we connect them up with each other
sure
here's start with a trivial example why
are you in this classroom right now
because you have to why why do you have
to be
for what i mean nobody's like you know
holding a gun in your head
to graduate okay so you you want to
graduate
so you take this class this is a
required class
um and i mean theoretically you could
you could just like not come to this
class and take the next ethics class
that comes around because they're like
trains you know
they're coming by every semester right
as a matter of fact we offer them
online at all sorts of weird intervals
too um
but you know so you've decided you're
gonna stick with this one
and get through it and you want to
graduate
so you have to study this discipline of
ethics
at least you know for a little while and
that discipline is going to be good for
you
you know maybe a variety of reasons but
one is it's going to
get you where you want to be um
now what did you have to do to actually
get you here today
oh yeah you had to sign up that's true
yeah but i have something even like more
basic in mind
what actually got you physically out of
wherever you were
and through that door today
your feet okay your legs uh okay that's
really basic now i'll go a little bit
higher to graduate your desire to
graduate okay
uh did everyone consult their desire to
graduate before they
got themselves here today yeah well i'm
not really just graduate
like you get a good grade yeah
yeah i mean you could have all sorts of
divergent reasons you could
you could take you know you you could
for instance
take ethics because you hate ethics and
you also
like inflicting you know punishment on
yourself and
you know that would be that would be a
goal wouldn't it right
i hope nobody in here is doing that
now you had to do what to to get here
you had to do some really basic
management of your time and resources to
get yourself in through the door you're
all wearing clothes
right you got that down you're all fed
i assume hopefully maybe you're going to
eat after this
um obviously all of you have you know
some sort of notebook
and or you know a laptop or you know
something like that so you can actually
if something comes up that you think is
important you can write it down
you've developed all sorts of other
skills haven't you that you just take
for granted
and those feed into getting you here in
class
and that feeds into something bigger
which is passing this class
and that feeds into something even
bigger which is graduating from here and
why do you want to graduate from
marriage
get a job right and then everything will
be completely
clear and you won't have to think about
anything after that right
if it's a job that you went to college
to get you're going to keep on doing all
this stuff when you're in your job
now what did we do there we actually
looked at a bunch of different means and
ends
and so some things that are an end a
purpose a goal
a good for you in some respect can
become a means for
yet another higher more important good
something that's getting closer to the
core
of what it is that you really want what
it is that you truly desire
and you notice for everybody in this
classroom we you know we ended up
where getting a job and we could go on
with that you want any job
i can give you a job i have you know
i have some money right here you know um
i need my my shoes i never shine them
anybody want to be my shoe shiner
but you get the idea right it's not any
job that you want
what is it about the job that you want
that's attracting you
money making money okay that actually
that's going to be important for
aristotle what else
i was going to say like the money that
like for like you know
to buy those things that you want in
life yeah money is
is by itself not particularly
useful uh just by itself considered you
know without
reference to anything else um i mean you
could build a house out of dollar bills
i suppose but
yeah during the during the massive
inflation i i actually had a
gigantic bank mark it was like
a million marks and the thing was like
this big you know
because it looked almost like a sheet of
paper
what else do you want on your job i
don't think all of you are here just
because you want money
yeah well for me i want to become a
teacher which has like intrinsic value
because
i like working with little children like
seeing their progress
and i feel like that would make me feel
feel better knowing that like i can help
them
anyway it's like an intrinsic value yeah
there are
there are goods intrinsic to every
activity that you guys are studying to
engage in even the ones that make money
there are goods uh for other people
there are goods for yourself
there are goods that you actually share
with other people and yourself
in a lot of these you know think about
one second think about the workplace
that you're going to go into
do you want a workplace where you will
actually
work with people or do you want a
workplace where it's going to be
cutthroat
and everybody is trying to screw
everybody over
yeah i think i think most people at
least want the first one you know why
because there that's a better situation
that's
you know your idea of your job is is
more than just
this shadowy destination point what were
you going to
have like say ability to have all these
history classes who are eventually going
to become
like something better for society so
like that
none of
in the them but like you just have this
ability to make kids do
whatever they want yeah what aristotle
would call that is the capacity
to take potential yeah and to turn it
into actuality
um that's very important for him we're
going to get to that in a moment
and i think for your jobs that you're
preparing for
that's part of it too you want something
that's going to be fulfilling for you
down here i mean otherwise study
you know whatever is going to make the
most money
possible do anything
it takes to get the money because if
that's the only
good that's going to come out of it why
not just be you know totally
focused on that um yeah
i feel like some people do choose their
majors based on like what's going to
make them more money
i mean i know for me it's not like that
because i'm a social work major and
every time i tell someone that they
laugh in my face
but i'd rather well that's not nice yeah
but
well you just did it too no i didn't
laugh your face i was laughing my
sister's a social worker
and uh so i know all about how you know
what that's like but like i know people
like my sister was
always said she wanted to be like a
journalism major she always wanted to do
journalism
and then she realized that she wasn't
going to make like money out of it that
the
amount of money she was spending to go
to school was gonna be so much
more than her husband she was making she
switched her major to business and that
was a business major
yeah you know it's interesting to see
too there's a lot of business majors
who then go back to school in their late
30s and 40s
for some other discipline not that they
you know that their life went wrong or
anything like that
but they say i didn't learn everything
that i wanted to learn i want to go back
to school
you know aristotle actually thought when
it comes this is a digression
when it comes to ethics we shouldn't try
to teach this to
18 year olds probably not even you know
21
22 year olds the way that we're doing it
here
you probably need to go out and
accumulate some some life experience
in the world of work to draw on
for some of these things to hit home
about value and goods and all that sort
of stuff
i think there's ways in which people can
mature very quickly i think he might be
wrong in
some some of the things that he says
about that but there you know there's
something to that
so going back to this now is there some
good that everything that we did aims at
he asks
if there is then
there's something that we could use to
orient not just
one's own life or one's profession
but also human beings in general that
would be a basis for doing ethics
if we if we don't have anything like
that if there's only goods
for say certain professions for goods
for
certain organizations or you know you're
good and her good and her good and so on
down the line
there's no general human good
even if it's one that we're kind of
vague about
then we're not going to really be able
to have much of a basis
for deciding what to do across the board
in general we can decide what to do in a
specific area
you know you can do things
hypothetically well if money is what you
want then here's
what you ought to do to get it if
respect is what you want here's what you
ought to go to do to get it
but there's nothing if if there isn't
one single good that we all
aim at then there's nothing that we
could like point towards and say well
here's our guiding point our you know
north star that we're going to use to
see us through
all of these different things
and it is possible to go off go off
course very easily when it comes to
these things
before i talk about that last thing just
consider one possibility for how you can
go off course
besides business what's another major
that you could study
where you are likely to make some good
money
yeah like medical oh yeah okay
become a doctor that's good america have
a pre-med program
okay so you go pre-med and then you do
med school
and you do your your residency and
all that and you get through it it's
like one gigantic hazing process
but you get through it and now you're
going to make a lot of money which is
good because you've got a lot of loans
too right
doctors and lawyers come out with tons
of loans
and that's what part of why they have to
charge what they do
now you engage in your medical practice
think about the doctors that you've
known over the course of your life
what motivates them different things
right
think about the best doctors you've
known what motivated them yeah
so i know sometimes he's a good one
right
to like come from the family i come from
so like
and he feels like he has to keep up that
like the reputation he established
himself with my dad so i feel like you
can still pressure himself
so family motivation yeah and i think a
lot of that has to do with his role as a
father
rather than a role as a doctor per se
but those are commendable qualities
what else can you guys say about doctors
that you've liked
would any of you like to have dr house
as your doctor
i mean he's you know at least on the
show which is done now
unfortunately um because that show is
about ethics you know
um he's got a really high success rate
doesn't he
of course he's a complete jerk and
really alienates people
but if if getting cured is the only
thing you care about
maybe he'd be the best way to go
what else are you looking for from a
doctor
yeah like compassion
yeah those are those are important
traits in the
medical professions and sometimes not
valued highly enough
now think about your worst experience
with a doctor
i'm willing about every one of you
having some bad experience or not a
doctor
a nurse an emergency responder somebody
like that
what motivated them in their job
let's assume they were actually doing
their job they didn't just like leave
you on the side of the road
yeah and they were just trying to get
you out of the office as quickly as
possible
ah that's interesting
i've had that experience myself too
so they valued efficiency they valued
making sure the paperwork was filed they
value
getting rid of their caseload or
something like that now
that i suppose isn't good in a certain
respect
it's not good to you because you you end
up like know falling through the cracks
but it isn't good to them and that could
become something that really motivates
them
money can become something that you know
motivates the doctor
they're probably not going to be as good
of a doctor if they're motivated by
money
than by
healing people making compassion
something actual
in the world you know yeah
oh that's an important one yeah i didn't
think that would come up here but
you're right doctors compete with each
other
and they compete for honors and you know
who has the highest
success rate ratios and things like that
lawyers are bad that way too
sometimes they do it in other ways you
know cars golf clubs things like that
yeah that could be the motivation too
and if your motivation is one of these
things you are probably less likely to
turn out happy
aristotle would say you're probably less
likely to
fulfill your function and thereby be
fulfilled in
what you do than the person who has a
better
grasp